hallo leute ich es wieder einmal wanne
und willkommen zu einem neuen test video
und bevor ich dieses test video startet
möchte ich einmal das flüchtlingslager
moria auf lesbos ansprechen ja ich muss
es tun und möchte es auch unbedingt tun
denn während ich auf kreta war einer
anderen griechischen insel brannte das
flüchtlingslager moorea ab viele von
euch haben sicherlich das video von joko
und klaas gesehen diese 15 minuten die
sie bekommen am fr 7 und über dieses
flüchtlingslager berichtet haben und da
höre ich jetzt schon ganz viele aus
ihren ecken springen und ihre kritik in
die kommentare reinschreiben wollen
genauso wie die kritik auch unter dem
video stand und ganz ehrlich wir sind ja
zum glück in deutschland und jeder darf
seine meinung haben und ich möchte auch
aufhören jeden der meine meinung nicht
teilt gleich zu verurteilen oder auf die
person herr abzusehen weil ja auch die
kritik von manchen menschen aus einem
wichtigen gedanken kommen aber es
fehlten oftmals schwer diese kritik dann
auch wirklich anzunehmen denn was ich
glaube was viele leute teilt ist
empathie und nicht dass kritiker
empathie los sind aber ich glaube mehr
empathie kann man diese situation besser
nehmen bzw einfach mehr mitgefühl mit
den flüchtlingen haben weil uns fehlt
eine ganz große sache wenn wir darüber
sprechen wir wissen nicht wie es ist in
einem land zu leben in dem du nicht mehr
sein möchtest aus welchem grund auch
immer und du weißt dass es dort ein
europa gibt einen deutschland was
menschen aufnehmen kann und wo es die
potenziell besser gehen kann ich war ja
auch auf einer griechischen insel auf
kreta aber ich war im urlaub mit
swimmingpools mit einem haufen essen auf
den tisch mit fließend wasser mit allem
was ich mir wünschen kann und ich möchte
einfach nur
falls sie etwas tun wollte und in der
video beschreibung die links anklickt da
findet ihr möglichkeiten zum helfen und
ich möchte nicht dass jeder mensch auf
dieser welt meine meinung teilt das wäre
auch langweilig aber ich würde mir
wünschen ein bisschen empathie von
menschen mehr zu sehen ich bin jemand
der vertraut eigentlich auf die politik
und die leute sagen ja so ist es halt
und ich hoffe einfach nur dass das alles
geregelt wird dass den menschen geholfen
wird und dass wir nicht anfangen
urteilen zu wollen darüber werde in den
flüchtlingslagern ist wer irgendwelche
brände gesetzt hat die es verdient haben
oder nicht ob sie ihre kinder auf die
muss mitnehmen oder nicht das sind
natürlich alles punkte die verstehe ich
auch aber man darf halt nicht vergessen
dass diese menschen in einer ganz
anderen lebenssituation sind und ich
hoffe ich werde es niemals
nachvollziehen müssen wie es ist in
dieser situation zu sein da sind einfach
nur mein wort dazu ich wollte es einfach
mal ansprechen weil es mir irgendwie
bauschmerzen gemacht hat diese
griechischen süßigkeiten zu testen wenn
ich über die situation auf lesbos zu
sprechen dankeschön und jetzt gehts los
mit dem video ich bruder mich kurz noch
mal nach und holt die lebensmitteln und
dann gibt es ja die tüte ich habe sehr
viel
mitgenommen es sind auch nicht nur
griechische produkte sondern auch
internationale aber die man in
griechenland kaufen konnte bzw auf kreta
und sogar ein deutsches produkt was sie
noch nie deutschland gesehen haben
bleibt spannend okay das erste produkt
das ist sogar griechisch glaube ist ein
croissant und red velvet kenne ich
eigentlich nur aus den usa bei david red
velvet cake
ich weiß nicht ganz genau was red velvet
bedeutet ob es jetzt eine rote
lebensmittelfarbe ist oder ob das auch
irgendein speziellen geschmack hat ich
finde aber sieht man sehr gut aus und
das hat mich sehr angezogen
ich hatte auch das gefühl auf kreta
standen sie allgemein sehr auch so
hörnchen es gab eine große hörnchen
auswahl
also das ist nicht die gleiche farbe
aber okay eigentlich nicht okay vom
machen wie es klingt und dann ist er
sehr gerne gelaufen wie ich mir mehr
erhofft ja also ich muss sagen in der
kamera die farbe auf jeden fall gut
widergespiegelt ich habe hunger ich muss
einfach probieren die creme schmeckt sah
nicht ein bisschen nach weiße schokolade
muss ich aber sagen so viel creme könnte
es nicht als kriegen dann kommt die
griechische verwandte habt immer bitte
die leute mehr erfüllung und die höheren
tieren reinmachen
dann spielen wir dieses hörnchen doch
mal mit bananen
aus das schwierige bei griechisch ist es
natürlich dass man die buchstaben haltet
also ich kenne die gar nicht und man
kann es nicht einmal erahnen was es
heißen könnte und selbst nicht lesen
können so selten liter auf der einen
seite unterschied kreta das heißt es in
kreta produkt komische war auf kreta
oder auch kriegen dann gibt es ja auch
kein fand und dann musst du diese
flaschen und alle einfach wegschmeißen
das war so ein komisches gefühl alles
wegzuschmeißen hier ist leute mit das
riecht nach banane haben noch nie so was
geschmeckt ach das hat gar nicht so viel
zucker nur 2,8 gramm und dass es wenig
in biologie ich erst mit 108 km/h ist
schmeckt halt wie eine spritzige bananen
limousine bananen limo getrunken was
jetzt bin ich überrascht noch nicht
komplett begeistert aber in der genau
dieses produkt hat mich absolut fertig
gemacht wird können wir in deutschland
aber milka lila pause ich habe noch nie
von milka lila pause gehörten ich habe
das noch nie gesehen die nette zeit
hinterm mond gelebt haben oder so aber
ich glaube milka geht uns in ausland
fremd so sieht's aus von innen
das ist eine dicke knusprige yogurette
so ist der geschmack sehr lecker und ich
glaube aus dem kühlschrank schmeckt da
noch besser okay aus deutschland bzw
griechenland gehen wir wieder nach
griechenland ich habe auf kreta auch ein
paar sachen gegessen die ich unbedingt
mal nachkochen möchte also falls die
sonne was habe ich im urlaub gegessen
travel edition sehen wollt dann schreibt
man gerne in die kommentare also bei
diesem ding war die verkäuferin so süß
zu mir weil sie gesagt hat hass bitte
auf beister nicht einfach rein glauben
wird schnell gecheckt ist mein einkauf
nicht normal ist sondern dass ich mich
so durch probieren möchte man hat sie
gesagt pass auf das ist ultra hat dass
sie dabei ehrlich hinzu hat wird für den
nicht so gut du könntest einzubrechen
es schmeckt die ein marshmallow der
schon über die flamme gehalten hast dann
wird er ja so knusprig und flüssig und
dann wird er wieder festen das ist es
dann ist da noch wandel dazwischen und
mein gottes ist lecker und durch die
mandeln schmeckte wie gebrannte mandeln
also sogar die ersten zwei zutaten honig
und danach zucker wow sind griechischen
lukas meinem leben gekickt sehr lecker
paket das nächste produkt was mich
angelächelt hat lively angelächelt hat
es wieder kleine freund hier das ist das
gruseligste gesicht was ich jemals
gesehen habe geht man doch kindheits
albträume von ich muss das mitnehmen
weil ich das gesicht im reallife auf
einem keks sehen muss um die immer
andere gesicht ich glaube andere der
nächste hab ich ein anderes gesicht ja
wir haben andere gesicht das ziel ja
machen wir das ding auf also ein meister
rote creme drin und braune krämer
wie schlau dadurch ist da die zunge rot
und die augen sind dunkel ist der
klügste kriegst du nicht mal gegessen
habe ich dachte ich werde die erp- crm-
nicht mögen weil ich künstlichen er bei
geschmack nicht so gerne mag aber
hiervon ist nicht so schlimm
ok hattest du nicht bist meine eltern
komme aus polen im sommer bin ich immer
nach polen gefahren und da gab es eine
marke seven days die gab es damals noch
nicht in deutschland da habe ich immer
so brot chips geholt und die blue chips
sollten wir jetzt alle eigentlich kennen
jetzt habe ich in griechenland diese
balance gefunden wird und
schaut euch mal an die hübsch das auf
dem bild aussieht und da sind pistazien
und cranberries drin ich ärgere mich
auch ein bisschen dass sich vor ort
nichts probiert hat weil ich glaube wenn
wir jetzt irgendwas mega gut schmeckt
werde ich mich ärgern dass ich nicht
noch mehr davon geholt haben naja das
ist hier wieder optisch aber trotzdem
sieht es ja nie aus und es sieht aus wie
ein richtig gesunder snack
ich wusste ich musste in deutschland
finden scheiße flecker um mein gott es
ist der perfekte snack was
kohlenhydraten du hast musst du hast
frucht rosmarin ist da auch noch drin
und joghurt ich esse das nicht mehr
ich glaube wenn allem was ich gerade
gegessen habe bei milch drin weil ihre
ende daran bekommt wenn euch mal so eine
packung 1 nächstes trotzdem probieren
auch wenn ich mich darauf in mir gar
nichts sagen und ich muss sagen im laden
dachte ich dass es marshmallow ist das
halt auch so lecker aus es riecht nach
joghurt der joghurt
glaubt man soll das aus dem kühlschrank
essen es ist so komisch es nämlich
kleben die nach joghurt schmeckt
ich finde da ist und dann nehmen was aus
dem mittelmeerraum kommt griese leid ich
kenne türkisch delight hat die vermutung
so ähnlich ist habe jetzt nur diesen
geschmack geholt ich glaube es ist eine
ziemliche sauerei
ich gehe mal ganz kurz ein stück davon
rausholen hier könnt ihr es in seiner
ganzen pracht beobachten war
es riecht nach rose ich habe mir schon
gedacht dass ich jetzt hier den rosen
geschmack ob es riecht nach ried nach
rose seit saukomisch weil wir in unserer
küche ja nicht so viel mit rosenwasser
und so was kochen schmecken bisschen
natur in meinem blume essen und die
konsistenz ist sehr sehr weich irgendwie
total lecker nur so über eine süßigkeit
davon bist du 1 unser nächstes getränk
ist nicht die bananen limo ich habe
keine ahnung was das ist hier steht
nichts auf das ich denke ist ein eistee
vom rat offspring oft armenien creed ist
schon wieder ein original kräder produkt
oder als wir durch kreta gefahren sind
dachte ich so was ist hier das sagen nur
nach berge und ein paar kleinen häuschen
aus und ich hoffe dass das mich jetzt
nicht umbringt das kann ich gar nicht
sagen wonach das schmeckt endlich was
ich gerade schmecke so rose ich muss das
spiel noch mal wenn ich mit besonders
großen habe große da wollen wir doch nie
war dies oft cookies ruby
deswegen das gekauft als wurde ja diese
neue schokolade entdeckt die ruby
schokolade die von natur aus rosa ist
habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch schon
tausendmal gehört das ist in der
lebensmittelindustrie saß eine
branding und wir gucken jetzt mal was
sie kann so sieht es aus wie sehen sie
aus wie so pamela rei kawakubo zusammen
auch in der verpackung so sieht das sex
und aus
ein bisschen unspektakulärer als ich mir
vorgestellt hab' aber ich weiß auch
nicht was ich mir vorgestellt habe und
[Musik]
der keks merkmal haferflocken ich glaube
aber die haben von dieser ruby
schokolade nicht so viel verwendet weil
die wahrscheinlich auch fire ist ein
bisschen mehr zukommt milch verwendet
also so schokoladig ist es jetzt nicht
nur mal gucken wonach jetzt meine limo
schmeckt ich glaube ich nachts zu kommen
was da ist 9 gramm zucker drin wo immer
das album anhören muss er hat mich das
an zucker wasser zwischen beim letzten
produkt und da sind wir wieder bei
meiner tollen market service data
willkommen und zwar einen cache borna
wie hübsch siehst du in echt aus
instagram versus realität also wirklich
positiv ist dass der kunde sehr flüchtig
ist
der restliche und jetzt wirklich als
allerletztes produkt was ihr euch
einfach nur zeigen wollte weil ich es
witzig fand sie hatten bei steam pulver
zum anrühren gibt es keine pointe dazu
was man da mitnehmen
das video gibt auf jeden fall ein daumen
nach oben das unterstützt mich sehr und
schreibt in die kommentare ob ich die
sachen aus kreta nach machen sollen wir
sehen uns dann das nächste mal wieder
biss dann eure test wanne